Kayla Mueller was seized by Islamic  state fighters one day after she arrived  in Syria she just visited a hospital in  the city of Aleppo run by the NGO  Doctors Without Borders she wrote a  letter while in captivity and managed to  smuggle it out to her family in it she  said she had not been mistreated I have  been shown in darkness light she wrote  and have learnt that even in prison one  can be free I am grateful I've come to  see that there's good in every situation  sometimes we just have to look for it I  know you would want me to remain strong  that's exactly what I'm doing the White  House says they cannot determine how  Kayla Mueller died but that her family  has received information considered  credible Islamic state claims Jordanian  missiles targeted the building in Syria  where she was held